welcome back to part two numpy my name
is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's WWMT learn comm get
certified get ahead so last time we
covered part 1 where we went over the
difference between the Python array and
the numpy array and why it's both easier
to use uses less memory and resources
and is also faster than the Python list
we also went over a number of the basic
features in there like looking up the
min the max the median how you can go
ahead and create some very basic arrays
fill them all with zeroes fill them all
with ones lookup the size the shape so
we covered a lot we covered a range
which is equivalent of Python well sort
of the equivalent of Python list range
and then we looked a lot into characters
working with the NP character and how to
capitalize Center it change it to a
title lowercase uppercase splitting
stripping joining and replacing
characters so what's in it for you today
we're gonna go over array manipulation
we're gonna go over numpy arithmetic
operations slicing arrays iterating over
arrays array concatenation splitting
arrays numpy histogram using net plot
library and a few other useful functions
in the numpy and then we'll do a
practice examples at the end and
hopefully you already got your Jupiter
notebook I like to use it through
anaconda but certainly you just use the
direct Jupiter notebook let's go ahead
and dive in there since we're going
right into part two which is getting
some coding going into our belt and here
in our Jupiter notebook we can go under
new and create a new folder Python 3 I
think I forgot to do this last time we
could just do the ctrl + + which in any
browser and large as a page makes it a
lot easier to see always a nice feature
another beautiful benefit of using
Jupiter notebooks and let me go ahead
and show you a neat thing we can do in
Jupiter this is nice if you're working
with people and you're doing this as a
demo on a large screen I'm gonna do the
hashtag or pound symbol array
manipulation kind of a title while we're
working on and then I'm gonna call this
cell cell type marked down as opposed to
code and you'll see it highlights it
here and then if I run
it just turns it into a Rea manipulation
and then we're specifically gonna be
working on a Rhema nipple ation changing
shape to start with and we'll go ahead
and mark this cell also a mark down so
has a nice little look there and then it
comes up and you can see it just like I
said it just highlights it it makes it
in very bold print just making it easier
to read not a Python thing but a Jupiter
thing that's good to know about
especially if you're working with the
shareholders since they're investing
money in you course the first thing I do
is import we're gonna import numpy as in
P and that should be standard by now
by now you you start a Python program
you're doing some data science numpy is
just something you bring in there and
let's go ahead and create our array and
we're gonna do that as the NP dot a
range remember that's zero what we're
gonna do is ero to nine and then it'll
print a little title on the original
array we'll just print that array a
remember from the first lesson so we
have our array which is zero one two
three four five six seven eight and
let's add a print space in between let's
create a second array B but we want this
to reshape array a and what does that
mean and the command is simply reshape
and then we have nine items in here and
this is so important right now so be
very aware if I did some weird numbers
in here it's not going to work and we
want multiples of nine we know that
three times three is nine
so we're going to reshape our a array by
three by three and then we're gonna
print well let's give it a title
OOP said to me brackets in there modify
it array and then let's go ahead and
print our B let's see what that looks
like
come down here you've taken this it has
gone from zero one two three four five
six seven eight to an array of arrays
and we have zero one two three four five
six seven eight and so we split this
into three by three and you can guess
that if I tried to reshape this let's
just do a 5 by 3 which is 15 that's
going to give me an error so it's not
gonna work you're not gonna be able to
reshape something unless the shape all
the data in their matches correctly so
we can take this 9 this flat 9 and they
call it a flex it's just a single array
and we can reshape it into a 3 by 3
array and first you may think matrix is
which this is used for that definitely I
use it a lot in graphing because they'll
come in that I have an array that's XY
comma XY 1 white 1 comma X 2 y 2 and so
the shape of it might be 2 by the length
of the number of points and I need to
separate that into X flat array and a Y
flat array you can see this can be very
easy to reshape the array doing that and
we can of course go back we can do B
print and we'll do B dot flatten
remember I said it's called a flattened
array and if we run that you'll see it
just goes back to the original one it
takes this 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and
flattens it back to a single array and
then one other feature to be aware of is
if we flatten it one of the commands we
can put in there is order let me just go
ahead and do that order equals F
strangely enough f stands for Fortran
the whole Fortran days I remember
actually studying Fortran programming
language in this case you'll see that it
uses the first like a zero three six is
the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight good now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight and if you go to the numpy array
page you can see here that they have the
flattened and you just open up the numpy
india ray flat and set up to look it up
and they have three different options
they have C F and a and it's whether to
flatten and see
which was based on how the C code works
for flattening originally worked which
is row-major fortran which is call a
major or preserve the column Fortran
ordering from a so whatever it was in
the default is the C version so the
default that you saw what you could put
orders equals C and have the same effect
as we saw there before you could even do
order equals a that would also have the
same effect because that's the default
so really the only other thing you need
to change on here is to change it to see
if you need it when you can see right
here or fi may not see the only think
you really want change it to is to your
F for the Fortran order which then does
it by column versus by row and let's
look at here we go reshape so let's
create a range of 12 and let's reshape
it I'll do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy I forgot the NP
there in P deranged and we can type in
just a for print or you can do full
print a and of course a Jupiter notebook
even have a little extra print at the
beginning we run this we'll see we
create a nice array of 0 1 2 it's
reshaped it so we have 4 rows and 3
columns or you could call it 3 columns
and four rows 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
but this one is so important we'll do NP
transpose a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if I get all the esses in
there don't leave an s out and you'll
see here we've taken our array if you
remember quickly we had 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 and we've swapped it so we've
gone from a 3 by 4 or 4 by 3 to a 3 by 4
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows the data
all comes in like let's say this is your
features in Row 1 your features in Row 2
and this is X Y Z well when you go to
plot it you send it all of X and one
array all the waianae one rate all Z in
another room and so it's really
important that we can transpose this
rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing I can
highlight it and do rackets around it
and if you remember correctly because
we're in Jupiter it doesn't matter where
we do the print or not it'll
automatically print it for us and you
see if I hit the Run button it comes up
at the same exact thing let's play with
the reshape and you know what the
student is up a little bit here like
that even bigger so you can really see
what's going on and let's play it the
reshaped just a little bit more we'll do
B equals in P dot a range let's do eight
and reshape I'll do 2 comma 4 let's go
ahead and print B and then run that and
you'll see we have now the two rows this
is a bit more like so we have four maybe
two rows of four things so this might be
all of our X components and our Y
components so we switch it back and
forth real easy important to note here
whether we do 2 comma 4 or in the case
of 4 comma 3 this has 12 elements and so
however you split it up it's got to
equal 12 so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's
pretty straightforward same thing down
here 2 times 4 equals 8 if I change this
and let's say I do 2 comma 3 let's just
run that in and you'll find we get an
error because you can't split a it up
into 2 rows by 3 you have to pick
something that it can split up and
arrange it in so let's go ahead and run
that and just for fun let's go reshape
our B again I can type reshape our B
again and what else goes into 8 well we
could do 2 by 2 by 2 so we can take this
out to 3 different dimensions and then
if course if we because this is going to
come out as a variable we can just go
ahead and run it and I'll print it we
could also do a print statement on there
just like we did before and you'll see
we have two different groups of two
variables of two different dimensions so
2 by 2 by 2 let's go ahead and assign
this to a variable C equals B reshaped
and let's do something a little
different
let's roll the axes roll axes
and we'll take our C due to trauma 1 and
if we go ahead and run this it's gonna
print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you draw the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 we now have the 0 2 1 3 4 6 5
7 so what's going on here we're taking
and we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with C comma 1 and run that and so if
we roll a single axes you got 0 1 and
then it rolled the 4/5 up and then we
have 2 3 6 7 and if we do too let me see
what happens there this is one of those
things you really have to play with and
start feeling what it's doing we've now
taken 0 2 4 6 1 3 5 7 so you can see
we've now rolled by 2 digits instead of
rolling the one set up we never rolled
two digits up there and so if we go back
and we do the one so we've rolled it up
0 1 4 5 well then we're going to take
the 2 in there and we've rolled the 0 1
2 3 4 5 & 6 7 so we start rolling these
things around on here there's a lot of
different things you can do on this well
that's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your numpy and finally let's
go ahead and swap axes we'll do C and
let's just go ahead and run that it's
gonna give me an error on there that's
because it requires multiple arguments
left out the arguments so now we can
swap them we get 2 0 2 1 3 4 6 5 7 so
you can see everything's been swapped
around so next thing we want to go over
is we want to go over numpy arithmetic
operations how can we take these and use
these let me just go ahead and put this
cell as a mark down there we go
we'll run that so it has a nice thing
alright nice title on there that's
always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
will do a as an EP MP range a range 9
and let's reshape this 3 by 3 so by now
you should be saying this reshape stuff
and this should all look pretty familiar
we have our 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 on there
and let's create a second one be okay
this time instead of doing a range let's
do in P array we'll just create a
straight up array and we'll do an array
of three objects so it's going to be
three by one and if we go ahead and
print B out and you run that this is
actually pretty common to have something
like this where you have a three by
whatever it is in a three by three array
when you're doing your math you kind of
have that kind of setup on there and
what we can do is we can go in P dot add
a B don't forget we can always put a
print statement on there so if we add it
you'll see that it just comes in there
and it goes okay we're adding 10 to
everything and we could actually do
something more Oh make it more
interesting 11 10 11 12 so it's changed
B is now 10 11 12 and let's run that and
you can see that we have 10 then you had
1 plus 11 is 12 2 plus 12 is 14 13 so 10
plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15 and 12 plus
5 is 17 and so on we'll put this back
since that's how the original setup was
let's do 10 by 10 by 10 and run that and
run that and get the original answer and
if you're going to add them together we
need to go ahead and subtract a B and we
run that we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8
just like you would expect
so we have our subtraction 0 minus 10 is
minus 10 and so on and if you're gonna
add and subtract you can guess what the
next one is we're going to multiply and
we'll multiply
a B and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply ten times zero we got
zero ten times ten is ten and so on and
finally if you're going to multiply
what's the last one we got it's divided
what happens we need to divide a by B
and we run this and we're gonna get zero
and this is zero divided by 10 is 0 1
divided by 10 is point 1 2 divided by 10
is 0.2 and so on and so on so the math
is pretty straightforward it just makes
it very easy to do the whole set up and
again if we went this and let's say well
let's change this up up here instead of
10 we do a hundred and make this a
thousand if we run that and then we do
the add you can see we got 10 plus a
hundred plus a thousand same thing with
the subtract same thing with the
multiply then you can also see the same
thing here with the divide so a lot of
control there with your array in your
math again let's set this back to 10
oops it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10 I will just go ahead and
run these and get back to where we were
this brings us to our next section which
is slicing and let's put in our cell of
course it gives us a nice-looking
slicing there and slicing means we're
just gonna take sections of the array so
let's create an array in P range let's
just do 20 and if you remember if we do
a we have a 0 to 19 and that we can do a
and remember that we can always print
these this can always be put in a print
but because I'm in Jupiter if you're
doing a demo and Jupiter that is it's
just so great that you have all these
controls on here so we could slice for
on and this should look familiar this is
the same as a python and a lot of other
different scripting languages if we do
four go 0 1 2 3 it's a first for and the
thing the skip settlement starts with
this one
the first for skip then from there on
you can also do the opposite and go till
the
fourth one if you read that we hit zero
one two three
quite the opposite on there we can do a
single item so we can pick object number
five on the list run that and five
happens to be five because that's the
order they're in and then this one's
interesting because I can do s equals
slice and let's create a slice here and
let's do two comma nine comma yeah let's
leave a two on there so we'll create an
S slice on here and then if we take our
array and we do array of s we're taking
our slice in there and let's go ahead
and run that and let's take a look and
see what it generated here first off we
started with two so we have two at the
beginning we're gonna end at nine which
happens to be 8 so it stops before the
ninth remember when we're doing arrays
and Python and then we step two so two
four six eight we can do this as three
let me run that and you can see how that
changes to five eight and we could do
this as let's leave this at three and if
we change this to ten whoops let's make
it twelve there we go
we run that we have two five eight 11 so
that's pretty straightforward is a very
nice feature to have on here we can
slice it and take different parts of the
series right out of the middle so now
that we've access to different pieces of
our array let's get into it er ating
iteration and this is interesting
because my sister who runs a college
data science division the first question
she asks is how do you go through data
and she's asking can you do you know how
to iterate through data do you know how
to do a basic for loop you know how to
go through each piece of the data and in
numpy they have some cool controls for
that just sends a mark down there we go
and run it it's called the indie eater
I'm not sure what the end e stands for
that indie inner for iterator so before
we do that though let's create an array
or something we can actually iterate
through we'll call it a equals NP a
range let's do something a little funny
here or funky and we'll do 0 45 5
I'm not sure why are the guys in the
back picked this particular one was kind
of a fun one
and if I run that we do this you can see
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 that's
what this array looks like and that's
just from our selects you could this is
just a slice that's all that is as we
created a slice of 0 45 0 to 45 step 5
so we can do with this we can also do a
equals V shape let's go ahead and take
and reshape this and since there's 9
variables in there we'll do a reshape it
3 by 3 that's if we run that whoops
missed something there that is the a
that really helps so if you do the a
reshape I'll go ahead and print that out
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 and then
we simply do 4 X in our numpy indeed a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
X and let's see what happens here when
we run through this and we print each
one of those it goes all the way through
the whole array so it's the same thing
we just saw before we got 0 5 10 15 20
25 30 35 40 so it prints out each object
in the array so you can go through and
view each one of these and certainly if
you remember you could also flatten the
array and just do for a and that also
and get the same result there's a lot of
ways to do this but this is the proper
way with the nd iterator because it'll
minimize the amount of resources needed
to go through each of the different
objects in the numpy array and hopefully
you asked this question why I just did
that and the question is how can I
change this instead of doing each object
so first of all it's going to take my
cell type we mark that down and run it
and so we're gonna work on iteration
order C style and F style and proceed
because it came from the C programming
and that because it came from the old
Fortran programming so let's give us a
reminder I will do a print a new for X n
n P iterate a but we also want to do
this in this
specific order and you know what I'm a
really lazy typer so let's go back up
here
it's the indie iterator I know I'm
missing the indie part of a let's do
order equals C we'll print X on there
and let's do that again and this time
order order
equals F flirting up order equals F
let's go ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing are going to notice our original
array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 when we
do order C that's a default 0 5 10 15 20
and so on and then when you come down
here you'll see F order F 0 15 30 so it
takes the first digit of each of the sub
arrays or the second dimension and then
goes into the second one five twenty
thirty five ten 25 40 so slightly
different order for iterating through it
if you need to do that oh we've covered
reshaping we covered math we've covered
iteration it covered a number of things
the next section we want to go ahead and
go over
it's going to be joining arrays so we
need to bring them together let me go
ahead and take the cell and make it
markdown cell type markdown there we go
and run that so let's work on joining a
race so we can bring them together and
with different options we have and this
too will do an NP array 1 2 comma 3 4 go
ahead and print this - oops first these
rays aren't that big so let's just go
ahead all on one line a
so if we run this first array one two
three four what's it for cut it
automatically wraps it when you do it
this way
so we'll go ahead and keep it separate
and print a there we go
and let's go ahead and do a B and we'll
do five six seven eight and notice I'm
keeping the same shape on these two
arrays depending on what you're doing
those shapes have to match let's go
ahead and print second array do a print
B wouldn't run that oops missed
something up there let me fix that real
quick reformatting it to go on separate
lines I messed that up there we go run
all right so we have first array 1 2 3 4
so gonna write 5 6 7 8 and we'll put a
carriage return on there
and the keyword we uses concatenate and
if you're familiar with Linux that
usually means you're adding it to the
end on there and we're going to do what
they call a long axis 0 so we have
concatenate a be along axis 0 let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
so we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so now we
have an array that is 4 by 2 as a nice
shape of 4 by 2 1 here and if we're
going to do it along the axes 0 you
should guess what the next one is we're
going to do it along the one axis and
let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axes equals 1 so we have our
concatenate we have a B and then axis 1
remember a couple things one of these
are the same shape so we have a 2 by 2
same dimensions going in there you're
going to get an error if you're
concatenated and they're not if you have
something that instead of 1 2 is 1 2 3 4
5 6 with a 5 6 7 8
they'll give you an error on there in
fact let's take a look and see what
happens when we do that let me just take
this 1 2 3 3 4 5 let's run that and if
we come down here we got there it says
all the input array dimensions except
for the concatenation axes M must match
exactly so it will let you know if you
mess up that's always a good thing
let's go ahead and take this back here
let's go ahead and run that and so we
have our zero axes which is 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and then bring them together and
you'll see a very different set up here
when we do it along the axes 1 we end up
with instead of 4 by 2 we end up with a
2 by 4 1 2 5 6 3 4 7 8 and this is
changing which axes we're going to go
ahead and concatenate on what I find is
when you're talking about the
concatenate or the joining arrays you
really got to play with these for a
while to make sure you understand what
you mean by the axes looks very
intuitive when you're looking at a taxi
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 X
one is then splitting in a different way
one two five six three four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does so if we're
going to do that let's go ahead and look
at splitting the array and do that in
the markdown and run it there we go they
have a nice little title there and we'll
go ahead and create an array of nine
let's do NP split we'll do a and we're
gonna split it by three let's just see
what that looks like so if we split it
we get an array zero one two three four
five
we have three separate arrays on here I
remember we're looking at just print a
up here so we're looking at zero one two
three four five six seven eight and then
we can split it into three separate
arrays and let's take this we're gonna
do this thing right down here just move
the a split down here instead of the
three let's do four comma five put that
in brackets and so when we do it this
way we have zero one two three four five
six seven eight
and that's kind of interesting I wasn't
sure what to expect on that but we get
when you split it a by 4 comma 5 you get
a totally different set up on here as
far as the way it split the array
and to understand how this works I'm
going to change the five to a seven and
this will visually make this a little
bit more clear so we had four and five
when zero one two three four five six
seven eight and you see the markers four
and five when we do four and seven I get
zero one two three four five six seven
eight and so that what you're looking at
here is the first markers this is going
to go to four so there's our first split
at the for the marker of four and then
the second split is going to be at
position 7 and this is the same thing
here for position five that's why we're
splitting it in those two sections we
could also do it
seventh let's just see what that looks
like run and you can see I now have 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so we can split it in all
kinds of different rates and create a
different set of multiple arrays on here
and split all kinds of different ways
before we get into the graphs and other
miscellaneous stuff let's go ahead and
look at resizing the array I'm going to
take the cell and set the cells of
markdown and run it give us a nice title
there and we'll do an array an in period
1 2 3 & 4 5 6 here and this will just
print
let's go print a dot shape then we'll go
ahead and run that whoops
hit a run button there hit the comment
stead of the dot so we have a shape of
two comma three here and this is
important to note because we start
resizing it it's going to mess with
different aspects of the shape and so
we're going to a print scoop in for a
blank line there we go us to be equals
NP dot resize
we're gonna resize a and let's resize it
with three by two and then we'll just go
ahead and print B and print the period
shape not a comma I'll run that oops
forgot the quotation marks around the
end I'll go ahead and run that and let's
just see what that looks like so we have
one two three four five six original
array with the shape of two three and
then we want to go ahead and resize it
by three two and we end up with one two
three four five six and we end up with
the shape of three two that shouldn't be
too much of a surprise you know we got
six elements in there we could resize it
by two three was original one and then
we're actually just reshaping is how
that kind of comes out as when you
resize it like that but what happens if
we do something a little different and
let's go ahead and just take this whole
thing and copy it down here so we can
see what that looks like and instead of
doing three two remember last time I did
the to reshape it I messed with the
numbers and it gave me an error well
when you resize it you don't have to
match the numbers they don't have to be
the same dimensions so we can instead of
going from a to three to a 3-2 we can
resize it to a three three so let's take
a look and see how it handles that and
we come down here to three three we end
up with one two three four five six and
it repeats one two three so it actually
takes the data it just adds a whole
other block in there based on the
original data and repeating it all right
now at this point we've been looking at
tons of numbers and moving stuff around
we want to go ahead and do is get a
little visual here
certainly you can picture all the
different numbers on there but let's
look at the histogram let's put this
into a histogram go ahead and run that
and to do that we're going to use the
mat plot library
so from mat plot library we're going to
import pie plot as PLT well that's
usually the notation you see for pie
plot so if you ever see PLT and a code
it's probably pie plot in the mat plot
library and then the guys on the back
did a nice job and gals too guys and
gals back there our team will read
simply learned put together a nice array
for me 20 87 for 40 53 with a bunch of
numbers that we may have something to
play with and we want to do is we wanted
to plot the histogram remember a
histogram says how many times different
numbers come in and then we're gonna put
them in bins and we have been zero to 20
to 40 to 60 to 80 to 100 you might in
here with the mat plot library they call
them bins you may hear the term buckets
or they put them in buckets that's a
really common term then we want to give
it a title so the way it works is you do
your PLT to hist for histogram your PLT
title and your PLT show and we're doing
just a single array in here in the numpy
array of a let's go ahead and run this
piece of code
taking a moment to come out there's his
finger size so it's chittering in the
graph
and you can see we have and this is take
a look at this and go down the size
there we go okay so now we can see we're
take a look at here so between 0 and 20
we have three values so we have a 20
here we have a 4 and a lemon and a 15 0
1 2 3 it's actually 4 values but they
start at 0 so remember we'll always
count from 0 up and from 20 to 40 we got
20 this was 140 2 3 4 5 6 and so you can
see in the histogram it shows that the
most common numbers coming up is going
to be between the 40 and 60 range least
common who in the 80 and 100 looks like
an age demographics is what this looks
like to me and you can see where they
would have put it in the buckets of
different age groups which would be a
nice way of looking at this histograms
are so important and so powerful when
you're doing demos and explaining your
data so being able to quickly put a
histogram up that shows what's common
and how it's trending is really
important and using that with a number
is really easy and you know what let's
take the same data and I want to show
you why we do bins or why we have
buckets of data I'm used to calling it
buckets why we have bins
let's do instead of by 20 let's do it by
tens and see what happens and what
happens when you do it by tens is you
miss out on you could see a nice curve
here in the first one and on the second
one it looks like a letter going up and
a plummet a letter going up and a
plummet and a letter going down so the
first would be more addictive of an age
group and the second one would be which
you would get if you divided in
correctly you wouldn't see the natural
trend
I don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat all fit knocks
I'm in 50 so I'm right in the middle
there that which means I need a ton of
food compared everybody else but it's
some kind of dinner maybe this mental
maybe it's knowledge because it's mean
we hit a certain point and we start
losing our marbles start leaking out or
something so you start off knowing
something and then as you get older you
grow more what you see here we lose it
and lose that continuity in the thing if
you split the histogram into too many
bins or too many buckets and if you
actually plotted this by the individual
numbers it would just be a bunch of dots
on the graph and wouldn't mean a whole
lot like the graphs there turns out are
a ton of useful functions and numpy I'm
sure there's even new ones that are
gonna be in here well this has cover
some important ones you really need to
know about if you're using the numpy
framework one of them is line space
function this is generating data so you
have a line space we have 1 3 10 and
when we do that we end up with 10
numbers so if you count them there's 10
numbers there between 1 and 3 and
they're evenly spaced we get one one
point two two two these are all there's
a total of 10 here in this right between
the 1 and 3 range that could be there's
a lot of uses for that but they're
probably more obscure than a lot of the
other common numpy array set up then a
real common one is to do summation so
we'll do some nation where you do this
case we create a numpy array of one two
different arrays one two three or two
different dimensions one two three two
three four five and we're going to sum
them up under axes 0 which is your
columns and if you remember correctly
columns is the 1 plus 3 2 plus 4 or 3
plus 5 so we have 3 columns and if we
change this we'll just flip this to 1
we get to numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals 6
+ 3 + 4 + 5 which equals 12
I'll set us back to 0
there we go since the service is really
an axis 0 and these probably could have
been smooth our math section square root
and standard deviation two very
important tools were used throughout the
machine learning process in data science
and simply we take the NP array we have
again the one two three four five six
three four five I don't know why I need
to keep recreating it it probably just
kept it but we can take the square root
of eight so it goes through and it takes
the square root of all the different
terms in a and we can also take the
standard deviation how much they deviate
in value on there and there's a rabble
function we can run that and in P array
as expert we're gonna do x equals eight
we change it from a to X x equals Ravel
and this sets it up as columns so we
have one two three four five this is all
columns on here very similar to the
flattened function so they kind of look
almost identical but we also the option
of doing a Ravel by column and then
another one is log so you can do
mathematical log on your array in this
case we have one two three we'll find
the log base ten for each of those three
numbers there's a couple of them they
don't you can't just do any number here
after log but there is also log base two
log base 10 is pretty commonly used on
here before we go let's have a little
fun let's do a little practice session
here on some more challenging questions
so you start to think how this stuff
fits together right now we just looked
at all the basics and all the basic
tools you have so let's do some numpy
practice examples and let's start by
figuring out how do you plot say a sine
wave in numpy what would that look like
and so in this project we wouldn't have
to do this because I've already run
these but we'd want to go ahead and
import our numpy as NP and import our
map plot library pi plot is PL T so we
get our tools going here and then we'll
break it into two sections because we
need our XY coordinates in here so first
off let's create our x coordinates and
our x coordinates we're going to set to
an a range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing sine and cosine it's going
to be between zero and point one and
then we use our NP and we actually can
look up numpy stores pi see how the
option just pulling pi and they're
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here and let's go ahead and run this and
just out of curiosity let's see what x
looks like i always like to do that so
we have point one point two point three
point four so we're going hero - in this
case nine point four three times numpy
pi pi is like three points something
something something that makes sense it
should be about nine and we're doing
interval as a point one so we create a
nice range of data and then we need to
create our Y variable and so Y is gonna
simply equal NP or numpy dot sine of X
and then once we have our x and y and if
we print let's go and just print Y X
yeah that will do this let's do this so
it looks print X print Y so we basically
have two arrays of data so we have like
our x-axis and our y-axis going on there
this is simply a PLT dot plot because
we're gonna plot the points and we'll do
X comma Y and then we want to actually
see the graph so we'll do plot dot to
show and we'll go ahead and run that and
you see we get a nice sine wave and here
is our number zero through nine and
here's our sine value which oscillates
between minus one and one like we expect
it to then for the next challenge let's
create a six by six two-dimensional
array
and let one and zero be placed
alternatively across the diagonals oh
that's a little confusing so let's think
about that we're gonna create a six by
six two dimensionals the shape is six by
six two dimensional array and let one
and zero be placed alternatively across
the diagonals now if you remember from
lesson one we can fill a whole numpy
array with zeros or ones or whatever so
we're going to do NP a created up be
zeros and we're going to do a six by six
and we'll go ahead and make sure it
knows it's an integer even though it's
usually the default and just real quick
let's take a look and see what that
looks like so if I run this you can see
I get six by six grid so six by six zero
zero zero zero zero
now if I understand this correctly when
they say one zero placed alternative
leaving across the diagonals they want
the center diagonal maybe that's going
to stay zero all the way down and then
the next diagonal will be once all the
way across diagonally and then the next
one zero is the next one one's the next
one zeros and so on and hopefully can
see my mouse lit up there and
highlighting it so let's take a little
piece of code here and we'll do Z one
colon colon 2 comma colon colon 2 equals
one and well that's a mouthful right
there so let's go ahead and run this and
see what that's doing and so what we're
doing is we're saying hey let's look at
in this case row one there's one and
then we're gonna go every other Row two
so I'm going to skip a row so skip here
skip here skip here so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns so you can see right here where
the that we're not touching each row
like this row right here is not being
touched okay so we're gonna start with
Row 1 and then we're going to skip a row
and another one and so we're going every
two rows and then in every two rows
we're looking at every two starting with
the beginning that's what this thing in
blank means so we're gonna start with
the beginning and we're gonna look at
all of them but we're gonna skip every
two so starting with Row one we look at
all the rows but we do we do it by two
steps so we go one skip one you know one
skip one one skip one one if you left
this out and do every one this would
just be once in fact let's see what this
looks like if I go like this and run it
you can see that I guess get ones so
this notation allows us to go down each
row row by row and we're going to do
every other row set up on there and so
if we're going to start with Row one we
also control Z
try that there we go we'll start with
rows zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero and we'll go every other row and
this time we'll start with one column
one and again we go every other one
going down step this with that step two
is skipping every other one we're going
to set that equal to one so let's see
what that looks like and you can see
here we get our answer we get 0 1 1 0 0
but it has the ones going in diagonals
on every other diagonal and 0 and every
other one a little bit of a brainteaser
that one trying to get that one to work
out so you can see how you can arrange
your rows and here's your step and your
different access on there and then the
next one is find the total number and
locations of missing values in the array
the first challenge is to create some
missing numbers so let's create a raised
Z we're going to do numpy random dot R
and 10 comma 10 and before we do the
second part let me just take this second
part out and let's just see what that
looks like so let's run that and there
we go so we have a 10 by 10 random array
it randomly is picking out numbers and
next we want to go ahead and take our
random integer size equals 5 and then
we're going to do a random random 10
size equals 5 so in the Z we're going to
select a number of random spaces here
and set them equal to null value and
let's go ahead and run that so you can
see what that looks like and if we look
at the array we've created one two three
four this should be a fifth one in here
my eyes may be failing me so we've
created a series of out because 0 0 2 5
0 1 2 3 4 so we get there are different
null values on here and
is kind of a neat notation to notice
that we can generate random integers
size equals five since generates five by
five miniature grid inside of this to
tell it where to put the Nan's at so
that's kind of a cool little thing you
can do and then we want to look up and
see how many null values are in there
and this is simply just NP is nan of Z
simple so if it is nan that we want to
sum it up so we're gonna sum up all of
the different null values on there now
let's do one more feature in here which
is really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
NP arg where NP is nan of Z so we're
gonna create our own another NP array
and let's run this and we'll see here
that comes up with the four indexes so
we didn't count four of them up there
tells you where they are 1 9 2 0 4 6 5 4
and then let's go ahead and run this
again there we go
this time I got 5 that's what get for
random numbers another fun one that I
always like to do it's very similar
because we have NP is Nancy sums we're
summing the number of Nan's and we can
get the indexes and you can reshape the
indexes but you can also just do we'll
do an IND s where NP is an N of Z and
let's just print let's print that print
inds
let's see what that looks like and it's
very similar we have we have 0 1 3 0 6 3
8 6 9 3 but I've split it into two
different arrays so we have our X and
our Y kind of coordinates going there
and what I can now do is I can now do Z
I end yes equals and at this point you
can also instead of getting the sum you
can get the means or the while the
numbers and that kind of thing if or the
average as it is so be one thing you
could do and you pick up the average
that's very common in data science to
get the average and just use that for a
value but we're going to just set it to
zero and then let's go ahead and print
our Z and run that and you can see we
come down here
we have where there was a null value it
is now zero and you can set this
wherever you want this is another way to
replace data or help clean data
depending on what it is you're doing so
while we covered a lot of stuff but so
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at a Rhema
nipple a ssin changing the shape how to
swish that around we even had the
flatten down there which remember we
have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by F
remember F stands for Fortran very
strange connotation but there's C and F
C is the standard and F switches it to a
different order to be honest I usually
have to look it up because they almost
never use F but when you need it you're
like oh my gosh it was the other order
still quick Google so we're talking
about reshape making sure that the
dimensions are the same you don't want
to have like something that has 12
objects in it and reshape it to 11 and 5
because it doesn't work it doesn't
divide into 12 we can transpose we can
switch them so we can go from a 4 by 3
to a 3 by 4 oops I did that the other
way around 3 by 4 to 4 by 3 we covered
reshaping the array we did the roll the
axes you can do some weird things with
swapping and rolling axes and
transposing the numbers we dug a little
bit into the arithmetic so we talked
about adding we talked about subtracting
multiplying dividing and you know at
this point it's so important we just
look up the number mathematics and you
can see here they have just about
everything your trigonometry your
hyperbolic functions rounding sums
products differences there is so many
different miscellaneous mathematical
connotation so you know google it go to
the main numpy page and look at the
different setups you can do on there so
we covered that and we're just slicing
how does break it apart we did iterating
over the array we covered joining arrays
and how to concatenate number
concatenate just means add on to it so
in this case how are you adding B on to
a is how you'd read that from Linux you
should kiss the
because that's used regularly they're
splitting the array we talked about uh
split the array in different ways so you
can split it in array of arrays all
kinds of different ways to split the
array up how to resize it and remember
resize does not have to have the same
shape but if you resize it it will take
the data and begin at the beginning and
add new rows on if the size is bigger if
it's smaller it truncates it it just
cuts the end off we looked at how to do
a histogram and how to plot that we
mentioned find buckets or bins as they
call them in pipe lot and then we
covered a lot of other useful functions
in numpy talked about the line space set
up for doing numbers in a series how to
sum the axes up again that's part of the
mathematical formula is there that we
looked at there's some there's also
means and median all of those you can
compute in Numbi and you can also do the
square root and standard deviation the
Raval function very similar to the flat
to be honest I almost always just use
the flat but you know the Ravel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenge you to
create a sine wave and numpy and how to
do that
we're kind of looking for that a range
remember how we do the a arrange and you
can have your beginning value your in
value which they did is three times pot
numpy pi and we're going to do interval
as a point one and then why just equals
the number sign of x there's our math
from the math page we were just looking
at remember that it's right at the top
and finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and ones playing
with the different connotations of Z of
the numpy array and then we did a random
size and we played a little bit with how
to with the null values playing with no
values if you're doing any data science
you know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small dead sets
of data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that so with that we want to go ahead
and wrap this up and I want to thank you
for joining me today again my name is
Richard Kirchner with the simply learned
team that's www.simpleandsensational.com